hey David you mentioned after the last
democratic debate that you thought Tom
Styer did better than a number of the
other candidates on stage who would you
rather have as president Tom Steyer Joe
Biden or Pete Buddha judge I am going to
take a position that might anger some
people or maybe some people will
appreciate it if you say the next
president or the next nominee the
nominee to face off against Trump will
be booted judge Biden or steyr I think I
go with steyr in in both of those
scenarios now there were people who were
opposed to styro because he's a
billionaire okay and we can sort of have
that debate Pete Buddha judge doesn't
have a lot of money Joe Biden is
reasonably wealthy and steyr is
extremely wealthy steyr basically has
the right positions or at least as good
of a position as Biden and Buddha judge
on almost every issue he wants to get
rid of capital punishment he wants to
end he wants to end the disparity
between coke the cocaine sentencing
disparity which is a very racialized
issue he wants to get rid of mandatory
minimum sentences he wants to get rid of
private prisons he wants mandated paper
ballots for election security he wants
to do a lot in terms of affordable
housing
he supports broad paid leave for
everyone several months he believes that
there should not be unlimited spending
allowed in politics on campaigns he
wants to end new oil and gas leases on
federal land and offshore drilling okay
his position on health care is not the
best but remember Biden's position on
health care is not great Buddha judges
position on health care isn't great and
I like the energy of steyr better than
Biden's which is almost no energy and
better than Buddha judges sort of like
ultra rehearsed weirdness steyr has some
other positions that I like on assault
weapons he wants to do a voluntary
buyback program which could actually get
a lot of guns off the streets he wants
universal background checks he wants a
national firearm registry which a lot of
candidates hesitate to say he wants to
do Medicare drug price negotiations I
mean it's a long list
and he would bring an energy that Joe
Biden
is completely lacking and that is to me
a more palatable energy than what Pete
booted judge brings so I want to hear
from you if these are the three choices
steyr Biden or Buddha judge who do you
go with also in imagining how they would
face up against Donald Trump I think Joe
Biden would not do well in debates
against Donald Trump Biden used to be a
great debater check out his old debates
with Paul Ryan excellent I mean ran
circles around the guy made him look
like a real fool made him look like an
uninformed kid essentially but he
doesn't seem to have it at this point in
time Budaj Edgewood you know he always
says if I were to Buddha Jen says if I
were to debate Trump I could say I
served where you got out because of a
bone spurs letter that might be powerful
but that'll last like 30 seconds and
then they'll move on to other stuff and
I think Trump has the potential of
making putas jej look kind of dumb
I think steyr of the three does the best
in debates against Donald Trump as well
this is not an endorsement of steyr I
don't plan to vote for steyr but if you
gave me only those three options I think
I'm going with Tom Styer let me know
what you think let me know if I'm crazy
have I lost my mind to say that I want
to hear from you